saint quentin en yvelines territoire
d'expérimentation pour la cybersécurité
dans le cadre du pack lido un projet de
recherche collaboratif coordonné par
airbus sécurité avec des centres de
recherche et des entreprises
c'est un pacte entre une des plus
grosses entreprises françaises qui a qui
doivent faire face à la montée de ce
marché après le numérique mais oui on
s'aperçoit que il faut protéger le
numérique
donc c'est la cybersécurité est donc ce
marché dans un d'exploser objectif du
pack lido protéger les données des
objets connectés à travers des systèmes
d'algorithmes et de protocoles
cryptographiques
en clair éviter le piratage ou
l'espionnage numérique
l'expérimentation sur saint quentin en
yvelines s'appuiera sur le système de
m2m une start-up incubés elle développe
pour l'agglomération un système
intelligent destinés à l'éclairage
public
cette collaboration elle est à la fois
avec saint quentin sur un terrain
d'expérimentation pour notre solution de
gestion de l'éclairage public et
également avec pack lido parce que nous
sommes le support physique expérimentale
de leurs algorithmes l'algorithme qui
sont en train de créer et qui va
d'ailleurs comme ils l'ont expliqué au
delà de l'algorithme qui inclut
l'intelligence artificielle du machine
learning et donc ils vont implémenter
tout ceci sur notre système éprouvé par
la testabilité que ça fonctionne
la cyber sécurité un enjeu de plus en
plus important 74 % des pme françaises
ont déjà subi des cyber attaques
un phénomène qui engendre 400 milliards
d'euros de coût moyen par an dans le
monde